[Music]
we're gonna let you change the question
these are all based on last year you
know they envelope if I open one and it
says moonlight I'm gonna be I'm gonna
laugh alright and you answer the
question there you go you've just been
gifted three billboards in a
high-profile area what would you have
them say Oh red event
stop texting focus on the road my kids
are in the car with me yeah there you go
very much thank you different and
stunning I'm quite attached to it yeah
Timofey you see what they it he is this
has been quite a run for both of you and
it was a it was a risky roll that turned
into one of the great true love stories
of the season doesn't mean to do a movie
that is groundbreaking in that way you
know we embarked on a project that we
all believed in there's a passion
project and the fact that it had any
reception like this much less the fact
that it's gotten up here on the red
carpet Academy Awards it's uh it's
wonderful nobody expected us have you
heard that Jennifer Lawrence really is
going to shave him that is her prize
who's not in love with somebody shall
available and we make a cute couple
don't you think sure for sure because
you're all covered up but I saw you
doing some chest
scraping yep what is that all about you
know you just got to make sure that your
machine is running right you got to come
here you got a peacock up and down the
carpet you got a break up the scar
tissue get it all tip-top shape